less than 24 hours after Jeremy Corbyn
came to the tea you see and spelled out
Labour's latest brexit policy stop No
Deal then trigger a general election its
deputy Tom Watson calls the new Rao in
the party by calling for a referendum
before a general election and for labour
to campaign for remain we should
unambiguously and unequivocally back
remained we should back remain not for
electrical electoral or tactical reasons
but because it is the right thing to do
for the country at this time of greatest
crisis since the Second World War
mr. Watson spoke just minutes after
Circus Dharma the shadow brexit
secretary told the tea you see election
first then campaigned for a referendum
Jeremy was right to say but this
Congress yesterday that an incoming
Labour government will commit to a
referendum later mr corbyn visiting a
college in Walsall in the West Midlands
was asked about mr. Watson's referendum
call it's Tom's view I don't accept it
and I don't agree with it
our priority is to get a general
election in order to give the people a
chance to elect a government that cares
for them not themselves senior union
leaders who held talks with mr corbyn in
brighton this week reacted furiously to
mr. Watson's move he is out of step with
what's happening within the party I wish
Tom would concentrate more on giving
support to his leader welcome to general
election bring it on but I'll tell you
this
no one's gonna vote for a divided party
so anyone who steps out of line thinking
for their own needs or their own gains
is wholly unwelcome and will be opposed
by the GMB many delegates and labor
activists will regard this as an
unnecessary Rao this conference ended
with Labour's uneasy truce on brexit
which had held together pretty well over
the past week or so abruptly broken by
Tom Watson it means that when Labour's
conference opens here in this hall in
ten days time the split will be laid
bare
again and it makes the task of agreeing
a settled labor policy on brexit much
harder John Craig Sky News Brighton